but the bible's pretty clear i mean when
you look at it you see you see the
father
right
it's non-negotiable you see jesus the
son and you see the holy spirit that's
what i love about the bible is that it's
sometimes so simple
but yet so profound welcome to led live
have you ever wondered what is the holy
spirit
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness all right
everybody welcome back to led live and
i'm excited again to have my brother
brock on the show brockmire um
thank you for coming by and blessing us
with this topic uh i i think that
there's a question on the table that uh
i see pop up from time to time in fact
whenever we mention this we'll see in
our comments there's people that have
very strong feelings about
what the holy spirit is or what the holy
spirit is not
and
i think it's an important topic
especially as we're entering into these
final days of earth's history so
i really i'm excited to hear what you
have to say on this uh i know
tell us a little bit about why you even
started um kind of diving into this
subject matter sure absolutely so this
was a topic actually that
um you know came to us locally with the
church that i would i've been involved
with
and we had some questions about the the
nature of god like the godhead itself
like who is jesus
and what is his relationship to the
father and then of course that brings
into question the holy spirit what is
his relationship to the godhead or the
entire entity right
and so we we begin to study this out the
leadership of our church and really just
pour over the scriptures and to pray
about this and it was an incredible we
spent about a week really just pouring
into this and god really blessed in just
illuminating the scriptures and and what
they have to say about the holy spirit
not only the holy spirit but about jesus
and about god the father as well
so you know i think this is an important
topic because uh you know i've heard a
lot of people who are against the idea
of the holy spirit being an entity of
the godhead
and they say there's no scriptural
evidence of that what is the godhead
god the father jesus and the holy spirit
so you know the fact that that there
would be an argument on the table that
people say hey there's there's nothing
in scripture that says this when i read
the bible it's all over it's all over
the place and it seems to be popping up
off of this page a lot i mean jesus
saying i'm gonna send you another
comforter and and uh you know he will
come when i go back to the father and
you know it's like you don't ever speak
about your your character as being that
you know what i mean so
um yeah i think it's important this is a
such an incredible issue to to even
discuss and i think this is important
for us to give pause
as we look at the godhead itself because
we're trying to articulate god right you
know and it's like how does how do we as
finite human beings even begin to
articulate god
and um you know moses when he met you
know god at the burning bush you know
took his shoes off because he recognized
he stood on holy ground so really to
approach the subject with the same
respect and dignity that that we're just
barely trying to understand or grasp you
know who god is and so this is why the
scriptures are so important in
understanding who god is is because in
the bible we have the revealed character
of god
and so god has revealed a lot about
himself and his character through his
word and so the closer we stick to his
word the safer we will be the further we
step outside of the construct of the
word of god that's where a lot of the
danger comes when trying to understand
who god is right right
and the function of the holy spirit i'm
sure we're going to get into that
has an important role
and i and i i see
in the argument that's presented on the
table is is almost like if you do away
with that aspect it leaves you
vulnerable
and so um i'm sure we're going to unpack
that a little bit but absolutely
absolutely
yeah you know we live in we live in
incredible times
and this is why you know the topics on
this show are so relevant and you guys
have seen this is that you know the
times which we live are just
unprecedented in terms of like what you
what you believe or what you want to
believe
um there's every option available to
people out there right now in terms of
belief systems i mean just this is real
random before we read this verse but um
next to my in-laws um where we came from
in paradise there was a property and and
they live on this really beautiful knoll
hill and um there was a property that
was next to one of their their houses um
had a holy spirit
weakened and it was like all about the
holy spirit and i remember seeing all
the signs when we would drive by their
house
and um i mean it was like lollapalooza
you know like bands out there 24 7 total
stoner fest
and i was just like how can you call
that yeah like like everybody's you know
high and you know it wasn't like what
you would think of like people getting
rather and praying i mean it was a
concert i mean there was there was glow
sticks and people dancing around all
night long but they called it the holy
spirit like weekend or whatever you know
and i was just like wow that's that's
that's really a different interpretation
of what i would have
expected out of that kind of a title but
yeah well i think first timothy 4
1-2 actually tells us why why we see
this okay first timothy chapter four now
the spirit expressly says that in the
later times some will depart from the
faith by devoting themselves to
deceitful spirits and teachings of
demons through the insincerity of liars
whose consciences are seared
who forbid marriage and require
abstinence from food that god created to
be received with thanksgiving by those
who believe and know the truth
so
really what you know in this first
couple verses what we see
is that in the end of time the latter
times we're going to see people depart
from the faith and they're going to be
enticed by these spirits
multiple spirits running crazy all over
the earth
and
really the bible clearly points out that
these are doctrines of demons
and you guys see this like in the media
that you guys are looking at and the
storylines you're seeing you're actually
starting to see narratives that are
scripted
by demonic agencies i mean wow i mean
talk about sobering times in which we
live
and on the confusing point like why why
do we see such confusion well the bible
also elsewhere tells us that that um you
know woe to them that call good evil and
evil good and so we're living in this
day and age where it's like those things
that are considered to be good are now
considered evil by a large majority of
society and those things that are evil
that have been evil for so long are now
flipped and considered to be good so
it's a confusing time the sad part is is
you know we expect to get haters on our
page from like atheists and things like
that but
a large majority of the people that hate
on us are other christians they're
coming they've found our page because
they are christians and they kind of
stumble upon our page
and they will
defend hollywood and and say that we're
the reason why people don't like
christians and stuff because
we're pointing out all the blasphemy and
movies so
they'll say well you know i can watch
this movie and just kind of ignore that
blasphemy that blasphemy
but at the same time defend hollywood
and say that you're crazy for pointing
this stuff out so it's like are we
really just gonna just
overlook blasphemy and
and uh you know support hollywood that's
putting the stuff out it's kind of scary
there's another point to that because
some people may say oh i'm not accepting
the evil you know i'm not calling the
evil good i'm not upholding it but i
feel like tolerance of it is the same
thing right or like keeping quiet about
it but the fruit of the spirit you know
love joy peace lung suffering all of
those things right when you have
somebody jump on the channel like this
is why i hate you christians then you
make a bad name for yourself and they're
like
christian and it's like bad bad bad bad
comment and then it's like you know in
defense like you said of hollywood but
yet you're gonna turn around and throw
your own christian brethren under the
bus and and because you know i i would
hope that what we're discussing is
profitable to people but i just find
that very interesting that that's the
that's the spirit that you often see
kind of coming at somebody that's
defending it well
and you see this like the devil is never
original what he can only do is kill
steal and destroy that's what jesus says
right so he can only he can only steal
that which is not his so of course he's
going to hijack the very concepts that
are so like foundational to god's
character for instance like driving
around town here recently we were just
talking about this before we started the
show was those little signs you see love
is why and i didn't really understand
the campaign behind it but i mean it's a
moving statement love is why i mean
right i mean love is an incredible
motivator within human
experience
and when you begin to understand this
from a from a correct biblical
understanding
you see that love is the reason why like
love is the reason why god is so
interested in humanity love is the
reason why god has given himself for the
saving of humanity and love is the
reason why god has even given us a
comforter a helper the holy spirit to
help us navigate confusing times which
he saw beforehand would happen and he's
like i don't want to leave you without a
guide so i'm going to give you the
comfort of the holy spirit right so god
is love we know this right first john 4
7 we see this from scripture that god
has loved but yet in our society today
we have so um manipulated that
definition of what is love
like
love is is is anybody's guess at this
point i love this car i love this ice
cream or whatever they i mean i've seen
i've seen videos of people marrying
their computer generated like whatever
video game character and it's like is
that really love i mean can you love
some in an inanimate object like that
and also some people have this skew
they're genuine they're sincere but it's
a skewed form because that's all they
grew up seeing so a child watching his
father beat his mother well that's love
and then continues that if he has no
other
point of reference that's his picture of
love exactly you know by definition love
actually has to have boundaries
and this is what's so important is that
if you find somebody who's fighting
against that definition of love love
with boundaries
it's often because they don't want to be
bound
like their selfish nature does not want
to be bound and so they're going to
fight against him and say no no i don't
want any boundaries because the real
definition of love has no boundaries and
it's like wait a minute
like if you really start to apply this
equally across the board you find out
very quickly that love has to have
boundaries
right you can't just take the woman off
the street for your own
with no question against her will
against you know i mean everybody would
say hold on hold on that's not right
right it's moral relativism
yeah what's right for you is right for
you but for rights for me is different
and that is chaotic
but that's why god put a tree in the
center of the garden of eden that was
off limits right i mean if you think
about it you have
thousands of trees you can eat from one
you can't so it's not like you know he's
not like
giving you this massive thing you cannot
do it was just this very simple act
because that's what true love is about
is the freedom to yeah you didn't really
specify but the freedom to rebel against
that being who gave you everything i'm
giving you the whole world i'm asking
you not to this one thing and if you go
against that then you're really showing
your lack of trust
and isn't it just like the devil to make
a mountain out of an issue that is very
simple
right i mean like just don't don't even
go near it yeah just leave it alone
right and devil's like what
like don't go near it like yeah you know
you need to understand why this is like
let me tell you about why you know you
need to eat this fruit and share this
fruit and all of a sudden now you've
introduced into our world for the first
time
rebellion doubt
that if you look at the course of human
history it's destroyed us
absolutely destroyed us
like what a profound thing that's
happening and it's the principle not
even a thing because if it wasn't the
tree the devil would have found
something else right you know if we
didn't have everything oh why hasn't god
put any boundaries he doesn't care about
you like it's just always something
right so there's some there's some
really powerful points when we look at
the holy spirit specifically it's
interesting that
we actually find this in scripture
that you know jesus is always pointing
away from himself
it's really kind of fascinating concept
like jesus always like i speak not my
own words i've not come to do my own
will
right i'm here to speak what the father
has told me to speak this this is the
the language there to serve i'm here to
serve he's revealing to the jews at the
time the very character of god and he's
not pointing to himself he's not saying
look at me i'm the messiah i'm the one
that's here to rescue you he doesn't say
any of that he says i'm pointing you to
the love of the father i'm trying to
describe to you the very character of
god and this is why when you understand
the concept of the godhead love is at
the very base of who god is like it's
others centered even within the even
within the the constant construct of god
the father god the son and god the holy
spirit
they're always thinking about not
themselves but of someone else within
that they have to be the ultimate model
of it right i mean if it's if it's like
he's he's asking that of his creation
then that they ha can't ask something
that they're not willing to
have amongst themselves right so i see
that as very consistent with the
character of god it's like he's he's
literally the best example you could
come up with that and you can see it in
just within their own relationship well
yeah if a being was to say i am love and
you say well who do you love you're
you're alone you love yourself that's
narcissistic yes and it's different than
any other
religious god you know what i mean like
where they're like i'm top dog and you
know everybody needs to bow down and and
do what i tell them to do and all that
you know all the time
without having that others focused it's
just this sort of like pyramid scheme if
you would exactly and so it's incredible
when you look at the character of god
you see that the bible tells us that god
is love right not god was love not god
does become love god is love so it's
this active demonstration of what love
is
now if we were to remove any aspect of
the character of god or who he was
you destroy that very picture that god
has loved
so god has always had to have been love
within within the relational construct
of three entities which is so amazing
when you look at this we see this on a
human level it's a very poor example
because again we're looking at the human
experience which does not at all project
upon god right but god does use but he
does use right we know that man is made
in the image of god like we know this
like man is made in the image of god so
here's what's so incredible about the
the image of god is that what you find
in the human experience is that at one
point all of us are in the singular
right
and if you grew up on an island and
there was nobody else around you
and you never interacted with another
human being the question that i would
ask is would you really understand what
love is no it'd be impossible the answer
is no now introduce another partner into
that mix right like you and some lucky
person get stuck in the island together
would you understand what love is and
the answer would be well to some degree
right now this is where love begins to
grow between two parties you see this
you're dating someone you're engaged to
someone you marry someone now that love
definition grows
but here's where it's even more
incredible now introduce a third party
into that mix
and love is just
yeah it's not weird like a child comes
into the situation and it's like you can
love that person and it's not strange to
the other person right so it expands
your heart and that seems to be a
microcosm of what the
big picture is all about something that
we can understand down here it's simple
it's in our language it's in our view
and then it's like if you apply that on
a massive scale eventually you will love
everybody and it won't be weird
so now you understand why there's such
an attack
upon the character of god when it comes
to the family
because the family made an image of god
is supposed to really be the best
demonstration on a human level of the
character of god like be fruitful and
multiply this is the original injunction
that god gives humanity
and now the devil's like man if i can
derail this if i can destroy this if i
can mix if i can call what's good evil
and evil good people will not even
understand
the love of god that is powerful point
you know attacking the family unit
because
two two people that are in love have
this infatuation that can be a very like
isolated
uh
you know it's like it's just me and you
like yeah selfish love like it's just me
and you here i don't care if anybody
else exists you know it's just us you
know and then this
crying baby comes in and i was like now
you have to show the love right because
that baby will die and and there's
things that god put in us to make us
fall in love with that baby too you know
right
so so i want to clarify something really
quick the
anti-trinitarian movement
at the base of their argument is that
god existed god the father existed at
one point
jesus came from the father was begotten
from the father and and was at some
point in eternity past brought into
existence right
so then there's obviously two but it was
like there would be at uh following that
logic there would be one point when god
the father was what by himself
that's the point is that you reduce god
to a single entity at one point in which
the bible which says god is love would
cease to be true yeah because if you
look at it in a relational setting right
god has to have this relationship i mean
if you're by yourself yeah you can't be
love if by their the very definition of
it is others focused you can't have that
and no other being is eternal like god
only god jesus and the holy spirit just
to um
maybe bring out a point something that
we're not saying i think this is
important there are people who can't
have children right you know they can
maybe adopt or something like that but
they they can't have children they never
had children
that's not to say you can't understand
the love of god
it's just we're talking about what the
ideal picture is right you know so just
want people to be clear we're not we're
not saying that you can't understand
love at all or you can't understand
god's love or anything like that we're
not saying that but this is a a natural
lesson that god has given to help us
understand this concept amen our limited
understanding yeah and thank you that
keith because actually you mentioned
adoption
what's incredible is that
even if that couple can't have children
and they come to the point where they're
convicted that they want to they want to
share that love and their life with
another entity what do they naturally do
they go out and they bring it in
and now you have now you have the three
again sharing that relation and it's
beautiful because it doesn't matter
whether that's their biological child or
not they come to a point where it's like
they are so in love that this is their
child right like even if even if it came
from them it would biologically it
wouldn't matter right and this is what's
so beautiful because even in that same
language of adoption this is why we as
human beings who are fallen but now have
the opportunity to receive the gift of
god
actually become partakers of the divine
nature adopted into the royal family of
god
and that's just incredible to think
about
so i've seen
programs on youtube
uh where you have these teenagers and
you know they have a
good time with each other and out of
that good time comes a child right and
their entire life changes they're still
in high school you know they're still
taking classes they're still figuring
out
life and it's amazing to watch them
learn
that love is also responsibility
because
you know whereas they would be going out
with their friends at night or on the
weekend or doing whatever they realize
no
i have the responsibility to this
person that i brought into the world
and i love them enough i'm not just
going to abandon them i'm just going to
leave them for my friends or what have
you it's powerful to watch you know a
young couple go through that
um maybe it wasn't the most ideal of
circumstances but they're they're
learning a powerful lesson
through that so it's kind of fascinating
to watch that so you're saying levels
boundaries well it has boundaries and
love is responsible right you know which
it was you know again you take it back
to the picture of god it's like
god with us god is showing how he's
responsible right you know it's like i i
made them i created them they're mine
they're in trouble i have to do
something about it because i love them
and this is what's so powerful is that
god himself
does something about it
like it's not that he sends another
created being to send somebody in his
place in fact and just a real quick side
note this is why
child sacrifice
is at the heart of pagan systems
because
because pagan systems are it it's all
about the destruction of that picture of
who god is right and what's interesting
is we find it i'll have to look at the
reference here but i think it's in
jeremiah where god actually says he says
speaking to the israelites he says you
guys have sacrificed your children he
says the thought has never even entered
into my mind
i would never sacrifice a child and yet
here you guys are sacrificing your
children so here's what's interesting
the highest
the highest expression of love and we
find this biblically that's why we have
to go back to the bible every time the
highest expression of love in the bible
greater love hath no man than this
then he laid down his life for his
friends self-sacrifice is actually the
greatest example of love in the universe
and so what's at stake here like when
you see that god actually himself and he
recognizes that humanity's in trouble he
doesn't put anybody else on the line
but himself
so i want to clear up something because
we talk about jesus as being the son of
the father right
in our limited view
we can only understand what a son and a
father in our relationship is
rather than three beings that were equal
all on the same plane and one of them
came to the table and said in order to
save this group i will step down from my
position and i will take the lowest of
the lowest seat send me
and and that's different than like that
person was underneath the father because
if we think of it in the ontological
like idea of what a father and a son is
then it's you just the son is never
going to be at the same level as the
father but jesus actually was the same
literally the same and he said i will
take a lesser role to go down there and
do that to to to save humanity and i
think that that is what i think mixes
people up sometimes is that that limited
view of what a father and a son really
are but but jesus was set aside meaning
like like he was now
um
set in a in a position that was you know
okay you're gonna be the one that goes
and does this that wasn't the father
saying i'm gonna sacrifice my son no you
know no that was jesus coming to the
table involved there's other scriptures
that'll point us to this that that be
and you see this like god actually calls
things as though they were before they
ever were
so we know this like this is something
god does right he's like abraham like
you're going to be the father of many
nations and abraham's like wait a minute
i don't even have a child like how is
that even possible but god doesn't see
that right he doesn't look at abraham
say yeah i see you're a single guy you
don't have your children someday you're
going to be no you are the father of
many nations right
so god already calls things as though
they were even though they are not in
the reality it's because god god is
forward thinking right god's fourth
thing so jesus could be called the son
even before he was ever the son right
the incarnated son of god because he
really is he's the incarnation it's a
mystery it's incredible to think about
but i have a question i mean i don't
know you derail it no no
um in matthew 28 18 it says and jesus
came up and spoke to them saying all
authority has been given to me in heaven
and on earth who gave him the authority
like that's
i mean these are like questions that
people would ask you know yeah so that
authority that that jesus is speaking
about think about it like if god and
i'll use a very simple illustration if
we have a stool that's a three-legged
stool has three legs right if you remove
one of those legs what happens to the
stool
it collapses right like
none of those legs is negotiable they're
all equal right well going back to what
scott was saying about jesus stepping
out of that co-eternal unity the godhead
where jesus is like i'm going to step
outside of this to save humanity well
the question everybody's mind is like
well how is it a stool and how is it
stable right it's going to fall apart
so the question in people's minds and
everybody who's watching right all the
angelic hosts
the devil everybody's watching just
saying wait a minute
jesus is now
willingly laying aside his royal robes
and taking on
humanity
which we know from scripture humans are
made a little lower than the angels like
blows your mind like wait hold on one
second how can god do this and still be
god
so the question is is a question of
authority the question that people would
be naturally asking in the back of your
mind whether you're willing to verbalize
it or not is wait a minute does jesus
still have the same authority because
he's no longer in the position that we
knew him to be in
so when he's he's making a statement
saying look the authority is still mine
i can lay it down
so
the other thing i would say to that too
is
in a very real legal sense
jesus did not have
authority if you will
over the planet
right because that that authority and
dominion was given to adam right so adam
adam had the dominion and authority when
adam sinned
that legal right to the planet was
removed
right and it was transferred
in a legal sense to satan the bible says
in john 12 31 now this is the judgment
of this world now the ruler of this
world will be cast out
the ruler is the one that has the
authority
so when jesus is saying now the
authority has been given to me
it's based on what he's done
so now he has the authority good point
good point good point amen
amen
yeah the narrative is we could go on
forever because you know when you start
to really dig into this it's just and
you see a picture of god
that when you say god is love in the
bible you're just like wow like god is
love i mean like he's willing to
sacrifice himself
for the saving of humanity and this is
why you see jesus constantly refer back
to the father right i have my own self
john 5 30 can do nothing right but
everything i do i'm pausing i'm
listening and i'm doing the will of the
father who sent me this is what jesus
says so when it comes to the holy spirit
you see the same relationship actually
with the holy spirit as well is that the
holy spirit actually doesn't expressly
speak of himself who does he testify of
they all point at each other yeah he
testifies of jesus right he's pointing
people to jesus
because jesus is the only way to the
father so exactly so it's this beautiful
picture of like unselfish relationship
which is just mind-boggling like what
was what was the biggest struggles the
disciples had when jesus was with him
yeah which one's the greatest yeah hey
i'm sitting on his right hand side right
the night before he gets crucified
they're arguing about that you know what
i mean and he takes off his his clothes
and and ends up washing their hands and
feet and and no means he's beautiful
right
right like servitude like serving
you know others is just an incredible
concept you think you go like all the
way back right to when sin happens
what's the
that god was in the habit of of walking
with them in a garden in the evening
right and as soon as sin happens what's
the first thing they do they hide
right they hide from the one
whom they knew that they loved
but they hide
and so since then
it's like the the picture of god is just
continually being corrupted
continually being corrupted right and so
it's it's like we're instead of running
to god we ran away and god has been
chasing us
ever since you know to try to
you know help us realize
what's going on
and so you know the you think of
people's pictures of god you know by the
time you get to a sinai
they're like we don't even want to
communicate with this being moses you go
do it we're scared right
their picture of god had been corrupted
even at the point of the flood they're
like man we're going to build a tower we
can't even trust whatever's going on
like
this being that exists i mean he wiped
everybody out right so we got to build
this tower
so it's like they're they're continually
picture of god as being corrupted and
jesus shows up and it's like okay it's
time to fix this
what is god like i'm going to show you
and when he says
you know if you've seen me you've seen
the father i'm pointing to the father
the disconnect people don't often make
is like look think about what he's
saying like whatever jesus is doing
and the actions that he's demonstrating
the father would do as well right
because he looks right
right
it's so deep incredible actually because
when you look through the old testament
there's biblical evidence that it was
actually jesus has always been the one
that has actually come and and actually
face to face met with moses met with
joshua met with gideon met with you know
each of these times that you see god
show up it's through it's through the
ministry of jesus the angel of the lord
right yeah and the burning the messenger
clearly it says the angel of the lord
was in that burning bush and when he
said who are you i am that i am that's
the name of god and so you know you can
make those connections there and it goes
back to what you said about you know
that incredible point when that when you
see jesus
you know healing the leper raising the
dead casting out demons this would
actually be the very same thing that the
father would do there's a problem though
is that we know that sin can't stand in
the presence of a holy god so like the
father couldn't show up in all of his
glory and all of his majesty because we
would just
cease to exist to be wiped out because
of the sin and the corruption that's in
our lives and so he has always tried to
buffer himself when he's trying to meet
with humanity like when moses is like
lord show me your glory god's like i'm
going to hide you in the rock so you
can't see all of my glory right so you'd
be consumed otherwise right or the
pillar of fire right the pillar of fire
there's a cloud that's shielding god's
glory and his presence but the desire
has always been
that god would dwell
with his people immanuel which means god
with us right
so
you can't handle god's love no i mean
that's a crazy concept right like god's
like i can't even show you how much i
love you like right in the open because
you would just burn up right and so i
got to kind of like dial it back a
little bit you know so you can actually
just take it on and i you know someday
we will get a chance to actually
experience that and stand in that fire
with god you know but look how the devil
takes that simple concept and he just
twists it turns it into a fearful thing
turns it into like you know god's just
angry and gonna zap you rather than like
god's like look i love you so much i i
can't be right next to you right now so
i've got to work through this veiled
situation right exactly
and so when we come to the holy spirit
you know the holy spirit of course has
always been present throughout scripture
even in genesis yeah he said my spirit
will not always strive with man right
exactly so this the holy spirit has
always been a part of the process it's
just at times that you know we don't
necessarily see him as visible as we do
other aspects of god's character meaning
jesus showing up god the father speaking
you know whatever it is that he's
sharing um so but the holy spirit is so
intimately a part of our experience that
it doesn't lessen but in fact takes on a
greater magnification when we come to
the new testament and this is because
jesus reveals about the character of the
father but he also says look i'm not
going to leave you as orphans this is
what he says right i'm not going to
leave you without a guide without a
comforter i'm going to send you a helper
in my place
and this is you have to understand this
when jesus steps outside of
the the godhead
you know to use that term because that's
the only biblical term that we actually
have like the bible doesn't say trinity
the bible doesn't say anything else says
godhead so
as jesus steps outside of the godhead
what he takes on is is permanently he
takes on humanity
which is really incredible to think
about like like he lays aside his his
his ability to be
present everywhere right so that poses a
problem right like he wants to be with
his people at all times and yet he is
now limited
by the garb of humanity
what a sacrifice but but but he doesn't
leave us as orphans he says i'm not
going to leave you as orphans even
though i'm physically leaving you i'm
not i'm going to give you
an the comforter who's going to come in
my name in my character and he's going
to be with you and he's going to be able
to be with everybody at the same time in
all of their needs in all their trials
and all of their problems the holy
spirit is going to be available that
little small voice that's in your head
when you know you're doing something you
shouldn't be doing right right and you
hear that subtle thing
that's the work of the holy spirit right
yeah and you see that right uh john 14
26 the comforter the holy ghost whom
jesus sends in his name will teach you
all things
it's like there's this really important
educational aspect with the holy spirit
that can't be
dismissed
and and we know that because like the
encounter that jesus has with nicodemus
like you know john 3 there's a chap
famous chapter john 3 16 the encounter
you know by night nicodemus comes and
starts talking to what does jesus do he
points him to the work of the holy
spirit he's like nicodemus you need to
be born again nickname is like what in
the world
what are you saying right and he doesn't
realize what jesus is speaking about is
that really he's speaking about the
office and the work of the holy spirit
that nicodemus needs a transformation of
heart that can only happen through the
power of the holy spirit
it's like jesus is the physical
demonstration of the model and then you
have this other being that's pointing
you to that model going look at what
look at what it's supposed to be you
know what i mean and that seems to be
the work of the holy spirit is
constantly pointing people back to jesus
and saying look at how jesus was look at
how this is a physical demonstration of
the love and that's that's what the holy
spirit's doing right we ought to
remember what jesus did here remember
how he acted here remember what he said
here
that's what the holy spirit is doing and
impressive pain on our minds and filling
in all those blanks and making it make
sense to us right right and in fact we
see this going further in john 16 right
because we see that says when the holy
spirit has come he will reprove the
world of sin
of righteousness and judgment now this
is a really key point when we're looking
at the holy spirit because there's a lot
of theories out there today even within
christian circles about what does the
holy spirit do and what's interesting is
typically we kind of have this gathering
like the holy spirit gathering right
everybody gets together and it's this
feeling this
experiential feeling that people partake
of that actually doesn't have anything
to do with reproving sin doesn't have
anything to do with righteousness or
right doing
right and it doesn't have anything to do
with judgment
there's a problem
because the central work of the holy
spirit is to reprove sin why do we
reprove the world of sin
well it's because
jesus
is the one who takes away sin
yeah this is a fascinating point here
because
sin and righteousness
they're they're opposites right right so
he's like i'm going to convict you of
sin i'm going to show you what
righteousness is and it and then the
judgment part is like the why right
right because there is a judgment to
come and in that judgment it's going to
look at the sin and the righteousness
so
where i think this ties in really nicely
is you go back to the old testament god
was already trying to tell them this
ezekiel 36
right he says
i will give you a new heart and put a
new spirit within you i will take the
heart of stone out of your flesh and
give you a heart of flesh i will put my
spirit within you and cause you to walk
in my statutes
right
and says and you will keep my judgments
and do them that's old testament right
this is old testament now it's repeated
in the new testament
so it's fascinating because god says
look i have a way a way that defines
what sin is and what righteousness is
and that is what i want to put within
your heart because that's what you're
going to be judged by
that's a good that's a good interesting
illustration that that righteousness is
100 like opposite of sin right too bad
we don't just call it wrongfulness
you got it right and you got wrong you
know what it's like but you can break it
down that way sin is the transgression
of the law which is wrong doing right
what is righteousness right doing right
they're exactly opposite which is what
he's trying to put inside of us his law
right right doing yeah there's the law
and there's a law so it stops so so the
office in the work of the holy spirit is
to stop you in your tracks what is it
that i'm doing that is wrong
and what is it that god wants to do in
my life to transform me so that i could
be on the right track doing that which
is right
and then why is so important because as
human beings it's like we should
we naturally want to know why like
asking why is not bad like in fact
there's there's an old hymn that i love
it it's it's actually a patriotic hymn
and uh it's i vow to thee my country and
it says the love that asks the reason
there's an important aspect to
understanding the reason
when it comes to love
you know and judgment and it's like and
i think as human beings we want to know
those questions why is this so important
and god in his infinite mercy and love
is like i'm going to show you why
like judgment is not to be feared i'm
going to give you the why
and if and if you trust me if you rest
in me like this is not something you
have to be scared of you actually get to
get to see the answers to all your
questions but i love it that the verse
that keith read to is is it's god saying
look i'm gonna do this for you i'm gonna
put my spirit in you so it's like i want
you to do this but i'm not just asking
you to do that and you just gotta try as
hard as you can right i'm gonna actually
give you the will and the power to be
able to do that because it isn't you
doing it it's me doing it inside of you
well now the bible comes alive because
zechariah 4 6 tells us this it's not by
might it's not by power but it's by my
spirit right boom i mean it's like the
whole thing is fluidly connected right
you start to understand see oh my
goodness like god's character is so
incredible right i think all of us have
probably experienced that you know there
was things that we
were in bondage to slave to that we
could not free ourselves from no matter
how hard we try and god gave us
supernatural victory you know it's it's
him he gets the glory for that yeah yeah
and it's a continued journey right now
none of us are saying here we're not
there
no no no no
there are still things in which god
when you have that daily he whispers to
you yeah and he says hey brock i want
you to work on this because this is
something that is between us i want to
come closer to you in this relationship
but this has to go it's like a marriage
relationship we're not all there like oh
we got the perfect relationship
we're done
i just heard an awesome sermon actually
a couple of weeks ago that was really
breaking down
um peter when he went to go speak to
cornelius and how basically racist they
were in the way that they were like i'm
not even gonna come under your roof and
eat with you right
and then all of a sudden god shows them
like no don't don't be calling you know
people unclean that i have not deemed
unclean right and so it's like you back
up in the story and you go man that's
the same peter that was the headlining
preacher at pentecost right i mean here
this guy's like yeah powerful yet he's
still struggling with something over
here right now so that that you know
that tells me like hey look god's
working on all of us we're at different
stages we're coming but i just i just
love it that it's his spirit that is
really driving us closer and closer to
that image of god so this is why it's
absolutely critical to understand that
the work of the holy spirit as a as a
personal
entity
of the godhead it can't be
can't be at all diminished right right
like you can't just say the holy spirit
is a force and when we get together the
holy spirit is in the room we're gonna
do some jericho marching right i mean
it's like you know this it has to be
understood that there's a personal work
that the holy spirit does very clearly
scripture points this out that this is
an actual
part of the godhead
and and when you diminish that you
really start to take away one of those
legs from the stool right well matthew
28 you you read verse 18 or one of
somebody read verse 18 um it says
therefore go and make disciples of all
nations baptizing them in the name of
the father the son and the holy spirit
if the holy spirit was literally like
god's character that seems to me a very
strange thing to say that'd be like you
know go out and do something
for brock and and his kid and brock's
character
right you know i mean like like it's
just kind of a funny thing to ask i
think that that there's there's little
pieces and chunks of evidence here that
that are like um you know that's that's
that's that's an entity well in this
verse here in matthew 28 actually if you
understand the context what this is
saying we understand this as christians
that this is
this is salvational
right like when you go into all nature
nations and you're teaching them all
things we'll go back to what we saw
about the work of the holy spirit he
teaches you all things right so it's
like there's these aspects here where
it's like this is non-negotiable like
we're going to teach you we're going to
disciple you and then we're going to
baptize you in in the character of god
father son and holy ghost it's really
powerful right
but you have to understand how each one
of these entities works on behalf of
humanity for our salvation that's why
it's important to understand so what do
you do with the grieving of the holy
spirit that's
that is a great question fact there's
the next one on my list here um because
that comes from matthew 12 31 it says
wherefore i say unto you all manner of
sin and blasphemy shall be forgiven unto
men but blasphemy against the holy ghost
shall not be forgiven
unto men
now this is a bit problematic i think
for a lot of us you know when we're
trying to grapple with this text what
does that mean exactly when it says that
god will not forgive us
against blasphemy against the holy ghost
so i've heard it explained like this
that we have a conscience that
conscience is the voice of the holy
spirit just like we've talked about
telling us like you know this is what
god is is requiring of us showing us
where we are falling short
and showing us the way on and pointing
us to jesus this is how we overcome or
this is how we do these things right and
you can actually sear that conscience to
the point where you feel no remorse
whatsoever it doesn't matter what's
shown to you what's told to you what
evidence is presented to you you will
not at all respond to it to me that
seems like that makes sense of why
that's grieving away the holy spirit so
literally that voice is so quieted in
your mind that it doesn't matter what it
says to you you aren't going to to
follow what it says that's kind of like
the pharaoh in egypt you know it says
that god hardened his heart a lot of
people look at that and say oh you know
god took away his free will he hardened
his heart no it's like the same source
that convicted
moses
was
hardening pharaoh's heart the same like
the illustration is the sun will harden
clay but melt wax same sun two different
substances
and
so yeah i guess pharaoh
reached that point of
searing his conscience to the call of
god satan has seared his conscience
towards god yeah so what you're talking
about sounds like it's someone doing it
to themselves it's like an
active thing but going back to our key
text in first timothy chapter four it's
the spirit is saying that people
through the insincerity of liars that's
other people whose consciences are
are seared right and it goes to the list
and going on so these people are
influencing others so what does it look
like exactly
for someone like the act of serving your
own conscience and actually being the
conduit of someone else to have their
shared
that's a great i mean
i think we have a lot of illustrations
from even just history on that
you know um
what comes to my mind immediately just
thinking is some of these individuals
that were so prominent within like nazi
germany right i mean like these are men
that are intelligent men
that have the capacity to do great good
or to do great evil
and they they followed a path
that eventually led them to the point
where their consciences were completely
dead because you have to be right i mean
to exterminate an entire group of people
like you you have to have no conscience
i mean to kill men women children you
know babies you have to have not even
just killed them i mean in the most
grotesque
evil way of just watching them suffer
and the children and i mean it's just
mind-boggling to even wrap your head
around like something like that even
happening but then the fact that they
just did it day in and day out is is
beyond i think where god is just like
look there's nothing i can do to help
you at this point like but then go home
and love on their own children right you
know exactly but but once again
you have to define what love is so at
that point you can love porn you can
love
evil you can love you know things just
the act of love l-o-v-e does not
necessarily mean that it is right does
that make sense right so i think that
that you know you can selfishly love
things
that would be contrary to the will of
god absolutely
even going to biblical examples right i
mean we go back to saul
right saul at one point was moved by the
spirit of god i mean he was powerfully
moved by the spirit of god and then and
then what's interesting is that what
really sears his conscience
is is his decision
to not listen
or wait for god but to take matters into
his own hands
like he says i don't need god i can do
this myself
and and it's that so i mean look what is
sin right the rebellion in heaven really
began over the indulgence of self
and the outworking of that process is so
dangerous damaging that you can come to
a place where you literally would say i
don't care about anybody else i'm going
to do what i'm going to do
because i want to do it regardless of
what the consequences to other people
around me and that's at the heart of of
why
god
had to step in
because sin is destruct by itself
destructive like even though it's
self-centered it is self-destructive
like eventually we would cease to exist
because we wipe each other out yeah
it goes back to boundaries right
boundaries it starts to cross and
doesn't know boundaries right
so so
the work of the holy spirit coming into
the end times you brought up the latter
times people are going to start
listening to demons and and you know
there's going to be two camps of people
found on the planet right before the
second coming of jesus right right
and uh i love the illustration of the
wheat and the tares you know as they're
growing up it's really hard to
distinguish you can't quite see like you
know what is actually a piece of wheat
and what is actually a tear like i
remember looking at an actual tear and
then looking at an actual piece of wheat
yeah it looks looks very similar
and as those two things grow up it's
like
you're starting to see this division and
this line until it is fully fruited
together and you will see a group of
people that it doesn't matter time if
time went a thousand more years they
still wouldn't choose god's side no
matter how many pieces of evidence were
shown to them i mean it's literally like
you've made your choice and there's
nothing i can do so why let it go on and
suffer more and that's when jesus says
i'm we're coming well it makes me think
of the time of noah god already knew
those people weren't going to get on the
ark but he
you know demonstrated to all the
watching people like they're going to
have 120 years to repent and they're
still not going to do it you know well
jesus says something very significant in
this context of this conversation
because he says by their
fruits you shall
know them right so when you really start
to look at and this is when we gauge any
sort of discussion or ministry or or
even even activity you know whether it
be watching media whether it be
participating in something whether it
even be pursuing a job or career or even
finding a wife or a spouse or anything
right by their fruits you shall know
them so god and his mercy has actually
given us a litmus test that we can
actually apply to any situation in life
well what are what are the fruits of the
spirit
love joy peace long suffering good
kindness kind of patience patience right
these are things if you see these things
as fruits of whatever it is that you're
a part of yeah then there's probably a
good indication that the spirit is
present
if you don't see these fruits it's very
simple the spirit is not present yeah
but the bible is pretty clear i mean
when you look at it you see you see the
father
right
it's non-negotiable you see jesus the
son and you see the holy spirit that's
what i love about the bible is that it's
sometimes so simple
but yet so profound like it you know god
does not remove all doubt like he allows
for people to make their own decision
because he is the greatest protector of
free will like he's not going to force
us to coerce us into belief but he's
going to lay it out so something that a
child could understand it if they so
desired
and yet it not be confusing
you know and so it really is amazing you
know and and looking at like why why is
this
why is this like whole discussion you
know we're talking about the godhead
we're talking about the holy spirit why
is it so important well it's because you
know jesus actually gives us a heads up
about what's about to happen in our day
and age in matthew 24 when he says you
know um
it's it's really you know pretty
profound he says in verse nine right
and this is after he starts talking
about natural disasters so we see
earthquakes famines pestilence disease
all these things but what's so amazing
is the next thing he follows up those
disasters with in verse 9 of matthew 24
he says they will deliver you up to
tribulation and they will kill you
you will be hated for all by all nations
for my name's sake then many will be
offended they will betray one another
they will hate one another many false
prophets will arise and deceive many
because
lawlessness will abound the love of many
will grow cold but he who endures to the
end shall be saved and this gospel of
the kingdom will be preached in all the
world as a witness to all nations and
then the end shall come now this is
incredible because when you really start
to understand the character of god that
god is a love
at humanity's darkest point
this is when god's love is going to
shine forth the brightest
is that god will have a people that will
demonstrate his love and his character
the fruits of the spirit
will be so
the stark contrast like when are things
contrasted
right when you have one that has and one
that has not right i mean so like you
have like a group of people that have
the fruits of the spirit and then you
have a whole people group that the love
of many will grow cold
like just the basic things that ties
together humanity will disappear we're
already seeing this right and we're
already seeing this in the world around
us that the love of humanity right now
is just about as cold as we've ever seen
it we care more about the animals than
we do about the babies that's true you
know what i mean like there's there's
literally people will fight you tooth
and nail if you do some harm to an
animal but yet we're we feel like it's
okay to to do terrible things to each
other so
we tie it all together right because he
gives the reason we go back to the why
why
are the the why is the love of men here
in cold
because lawlessness will abound right
what is it that he said he wanted to do
you know you you take ezekiel 36 you
fast forward to hebrews 8. he says i
will put my law
in your heart
right i'll write it upon your heart what
is the spirit doing he's convicting the
world of sin and of righteousness
because there's a judgment so what's the
difference between the two groups
right the ones that are loving
are obedient
right they're obedient to god and he's
and he says that he says there's a verse
in
where is it
acts 5 32 and we are his and witnesses
to these things and so also is the holy
spirit whom god has given to those who
obey him interesting wow good verse so
the spirit is given to those who obey
them so they're they're the law-abiding
ones they're the loving ones they're
displaying the fruits of the spirit in
contrast to their people who have fallen
away
you know which doesn't happen overnight
right
and the world is demonstrating that
they're they're becoming unloving
they're becoming lawless or they're
becoming unloving because they're
lawless right that law doesn't exist
in their heart like it's supposed to
you know there's a lot of talk at the
end of time about stealing right we know
this right like we see in revelation
chapter
um you know even 18 right that there's
this this ceiling the whole the winds of
strifer being withdrawn and then it's
like the whole
question is that there's this one being
that steps in the way and says hold on
don't hurt the earth until my servants
are sealed in their foreheads right what
does that mean and here's what's really
interesting right ephesians 4 30. some
of these verses that maybe we've always
read over glossed over kind of been
there in the back of our minds all of a
sudden take on an incredibly powerful
meaning when we understand the character
of god because this is what it says it
says and grieve not the holy spirit of
god
well why well because we know that
blasphemy or grieving the holy spirit is
the one thing that's not forgivable
right
first of all right but it says and
grieve not the holy spirit of god
whereby you are sealed
until the day of redemption
right let all bitterness this it even
goes further let all bitterness wrath
anger clamor evil speaking be put away
from you with all malice and i love this
and be ye kind one to another
tenderhearted forgiving one another even
as god for christ's sake has forgiven
you the fruits
the fruits of the spirit right there in
ephesians 4. i mean it's like
beautifully the scriptures ties it
together we begin to understand why this
great controversy is coming to a head
is because god's character is on full
display and there will be a people that
will be kind and tenderhearted one to
another forgiving one another even as
god has forgiven them in the most
darkest hour in the worst possible
position it was like you know god god
always does these mighty things when
when your back is against the wall right
you're backed up against the red sea i
mean there's no way out the whole
egyptian army is coming and that's when
god does his most mighty work so what a
demonstration of this war to finally end
without any question or whatever to
display it on the on the table and
literally say look in the most
impossible situation i'm going to put my
spirit in people and i'm going to seal
him and i'm going to step back and let
you see what the character of god is
really like yeah it's beautiful
the question i always ask is how do you
flip the script
you know like we're coming to a point
where the script is so dark it's so
demonic
how do you flip the script
and and you see this in the experience
of stephen right like steven is dragged
before the council
they have nothing but murder in their
heart like we know where this is headed
right
and even as they're stoning him
stephen is praying for him is praying
for them
and he's saying father forgive them
don't lay this sin at their charge
and this is what flips the script for
saul
right like saul like he's the one that's
personal church and all of a sudden it
doesn't compute like what in the world
how can this man
who
were obviously putting to death because
he's in the wrong and yet he's praying
for us
saying father forgive them don't lay the
sin at the charge and you see this with
all martyrs across the board like this
is the same kind of language that they
pray like lord open the eyes of the king
of england right because the flames are
rising you know and it's it's just like
people are just like in awe because they
they glimpse a picture of god yeah
jesus on the cross forget asking
forgiveness for those who are killing
them and then that roman said surely
this is the son of god yeah
i think it's beautiful that shows god
through and through
you think about
and you think about this a seal like
what does it do it preserves
right
it protects completes
yeah and i think that's that's necessary
and can only be done by god because you
enter that time
as bad as it's going to be the worst
time in history
what do natural inclinations want to do
and you've you gotta say no i'm gonna
give you my spirit
we're gonna seal you
and make sure that you're preserved
right
against yourself you know essentially
against that
evil character that wants to come out
it's going to be my character
and sealed
for forever and and the only response
that the evil world can come up with is
let's take them out
like like they're a standing rebuke to
our life
let's take them out well it said they
will hate you they'll kill you for his
name sake his character's sake and then
in revelation 12 17 and 14 12 and 22 14
it's all about an attack on those who
are obedient to him who have his
character you know
those who keep the commandments of god
are the ones that he's making war
against it says
yeah this study is so in-depth we could
go on forever
and um you know it just
it man
i love what you know what paul even says
in hebrews right
because
what we have is is the observation of
the universe right so he says like
because we're surrounded by such a cloud
of witnesses he's like let's lay aside
every weight and let's run this final
race with patience right looking to the
auth and the finish of our faith which
is jesus christ so what an incredible
like charge that paul gives us right
because he comes the end of his life and
he recognizes what's at stake
like the very character of god is at
stake
he's not just witnessing to nero in rome
and the others that are trying to behead
him
he realizes that this is a demonstration
of god's character to the universe
and so like what what a privilege what
an honor that god would even consider us
and invite us right partakers of the
divine nature would even offer that
extension to us to give us redemption to
give us salvation to give us that chance
to say
you can be
a part of my family you can take on my
name and you can do it by my spirit i
can write my law in your heart i can
cause you to do this and you can run the
greatest race that this world has ever
seen
and demonstrate like never before why my
character
is to be worshipped boy that really puts
a light on the context of what we are
doing i mean if you really think about
all these little actions have a literal
spreading of the of the truth of the
character of god to the universe
and the and the responsibility that that
is is is there it's pretty amazing brock
this is awesome yeah um thank you so
much for for breaking this down i i like
you said you could probably go on and on
and on i mean this is such a
deep neat topic um i'm sure we're gonna
have to circle back around and keep this
going but thank you so much for for
coming on the show and you know like
mikey's shirt says right here led by the
spirit uh brothers and sisters we want
to be led by the spirit
and uh i i believe if you have questions
real honest questions if you approach
god and say lord
show me the truth i want to see the
truth and help my heart to respond to
that truth if that is your desire i i
stand firm on this and we've said this a
million times on this show god will not
ignore you he will lead you in truth and
that's what he promises thank you guys
for stopping by and watching our show
and we'll hope that you come back again
and again thank you so much we'll see
you next week
[Music]
i
am the god of the new world
i love anime
i love it i mean i can't watch enough of
this the dualist who they say can speak
with the spirits the sins will destroy
the commandments forever a suspicious
list of names prompts an investigation
at a local school and concern for
parents the death note is derived from
the japanese animated show the girl told
authorities she got the idea from a
cartoon network show
mom it's mr satan i recognize that voice
anywhere
[Applause]
visit our brothers at school for profits
dot tv and watch from babylon to america
which has over 5 million views on
youtube alone and follow it up with
america 2 babylon check the description
below for links to this and more
[Music]
you